on continue notre série de podcasts
concernant les candidats à la draft NBA
2023 des portraits un podcast par joueur
un profil par podcast dans celui-ci le
profil de Nyx Metz junior
[Musique]
Nick Smith junior joueur darkansas cette
saison NCA né le 18 avril 2004 1 m 96 84
kg en tout cas c'est les mensurations
qu'on a il n'a pas été mesuré au NBA
combine nous l'avons vingtième sur notre
big board envergure à l'heure à laquelle
je parle c'est le mercredi 14 juin
ispienne la 14e meilleur joueur de cette
draft the athletic 19ème the Ringer 18e
pour en parler Manu et Julien salut Manu
salut Alex
salut à vous deux juge je t'ai demandé
de te pencher sur le parcours de nous
faire un petit résumé de la vie s'il y a
des choses à dire la biographie on va
dire avant de parler basket de Nyx Smith
junior Nicolas donc apparemment tu viens
de me l'apprendre Nicolas
quelque part il a grandi il est né il a
grandi dans l'Arkansas
à Jacksonville
il a rejoint le High School de North
Little Rock en 2021 pour son année
seniors avec lequel il a joué avec quel
elwer un autre prospect
qui ne s'est pas maintenu cette année à
la draft on va sûrement l'année
prochaine
très vite sous les radars de tous les
scouts il a participé à l'Open
McDonald's
il a été membre de l'équipe
des États-Unis au Night Ops il a
participé c'est un joueur qui est sous
les radars depuis très longtemps
il a été recruté par Arkansas avec
Jordan Wolf et les deux d'après ce qu'il
raconte dans des interviews ils ont fait
un petit peu le le comment dire le
forcing pour faire venir Anthony black
donc formé le trio 5 étoiles de
Max cette année voilà donc il arrive
dans à Kansas barder de distinction
d'avanceaison qui lui promettait un joli
une jolie année puisque il est c'était
un top 3 recrue je ne croise sur toute
la nation
même en pré-saison nous on l'avait
effectivement
un top 5 quasi assuré quoi il était dans
le même dans le même zoo que les amen
Tomson et compagnie quand on a commencé
la saison un peu glisser
un peu glissé
14 comme titulaire il s'est blessé au
genou en fait il a eu mal toute l'année
donc je pense qu'on va reparler jusqu'à
sa fin de saison un petit peu
au nom de Bouddha à la marque madness
comme ça ce qui est pas allé très loin
effectivement la marche maness avant de
d'évoquer les qualités les défauts de
Nick Smith Manu quel qu'est-ce qu'on lui
demandait de faire cette année du côté
de Arkansas qui était donc une équipe
très jeune
ouais et surtout sorti du banc du fait
de des blessures
au genou et pas que donc il a été il est
très vite il s'est mis petit à petit
dans le dans le rythme il avait très peu
la il y avait pas trop trop de match où
il avait vraiment le le ballon en main
dans mes souvenirs c'est venu un peu
même s'il a un très fort taux d'usage
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il soit aussi
haut à 26 ou 25 26
je m'attendais pas à ce qui se fait
aussi mais en fait il est il a très vite
rentré dans le rythme de l'équipe
surtout en fin de saison où il joue les
les 10 15 derniers matchs de mémoire et
en fait il voilà beaucoup d'attaques
beaucoup d'attaques du panier vraiment
c'est vrai ça vraiment ça qui l'a montré
sur le maillot d'art comme ça autrement
en termes de
extérieur c'était beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins fluide on sent que c'est
vraiment que c'est là que ça pêche
encore donc c'était vraiment beaucoup de
stage vers le cercle tout le temps ok ok
donc un rôle de stage de slasher
et défensivement ce qu'on lui donnait
des responsabilités pas nécessairement
non pas trop
sans plus quoi pas une voilà
user son taf ouais il était pas c'était
plus son coéquipier Anthony black qui
est projeté plus haut qui défendait les
meilleurs extérieurs adverses ou Ricky
Council
qui se présente également à cette draft
Julien quel qu'est-ce qu'on achète quand
on si on draft Nyx Smith le soir le soir
de la draft si on décide d'appuyer sur
le bouton et de sélectionner mix
pourquoi on le fait en tant que GM
alors ça dépend ce qu'on dit ce qu'on
comptait acheter alors on peut dire ça
est-ce qu'il a montré assez cette saison
de ce qu'on attendait de lui il était
annoncé comme un scorer à trois niveaux
sont extérieur quand il y a une shoot un
slasher effectivement et puis avoir un
petit un petit Midge un flotteur
voilà on attendait une un attaquant un
petit peu
versatile et
bon c'est pas comme un dymanus c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'on a vu après il y a des
flashs plein de choses on parle des
flash tout de suite ou tu veux qu'on
insiste sur des points je te demande
vraiment c'est quoi son petit calendrier
en NBA en fait
un arrière capable de scorer et avec une
tendance à créer du jeu on attaque ce
que je répondrais
ok Manu est-ce que tu vois d'autres
choses à l'arc de Nick Smith junior non
je suis assez dans le dos je suis dans
la même lignée que Julien c'est un mec
qui va du coup dans le spacing NBA les
règles NBA vont l'aider à attaquer
encore plus le cercle est encore
beaucoup plus productif en fait
s'il tombe dans un contexte où il est il
a des minutes soit en première unique ou
en seconde je pense que il va il va il
peut vite avoir un impact en fait
de cette façon là
parce que alors il attaque le cercle
mais provoque peu de lancer franc quand
même cette année on a un freet donc
c'est le nombre de lancers francs par
rapport au nombre de tirs tentés qui est
qui est la seule qui a moins de 25 ce
qui est ce qui est relativement faible
et effectivement la majorité de ces tirs
c'est quand même des longs deux points
c'est pas des tirs au Cercle quoi alors
c'est beaucoup dans le flotteur et il a
un pour ça je correct à 36% mais c'est
pas non plus extraordinaire
sur sur ces autres de points et puis
surtout c'est pas des tirs qui sont
statistiquement très enviable
pour vous quelle est la clé du coup
parce que entre le nyxmith qu'on
attendait et une x-mice qu'on a eu il y
a eu un monde quoi c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui moi
beaucoup regarder les stats mais les
joueurs avec une efficacité si horrible
parce qu'on parle quand même d'un
efficient feel goal personage à 43,6
c'est vraiment cataclysmique les mêmes
je veux dire par exemple à Anthony
Edouard
qui prenait des choux de casse-croûte
dans une équipe de la même conférence un
peu
avec peu de gens autour quoi il était
plus haut que ça il était vers 48 49 de
mémoire ce qui était déjà mauvais
Nick Smith c'est cataclysmique pour
retrouver un joueur drafté au premier
tour avec ce niveau là de efficient feel
goal personage il y en a mais il y en a
peu qu'on pas qu'on réussit à NBA donc
est-ce que déjà Julien est-ce que tu
penses qu'on a vu le vrai nixmis ou
est-ce que tu penses vraiment qu'il a
été gêné toute la saison
par cette blessures
les stats sont kata après à regarder
dans la saison il y a plusieurs choses
dont on peut parler d'abord il y a
effectivement il a été blessé il a dit
dans les interviews qu'il avait en fait
il a eu mal tout le temps au genou qui
soit sur le terrain où en dehors il
avait du mal à
soigner cette blessure donc ça c'est un
point d'interrogation et puis après il y
a le spaceing de il faut parler du
contexte arkan ça souviens pas de
piscine quoi il y avait pas de shooter
il y avait un autre auteur qui s'est
blessé bah vas-y
dans l'équipe c'est blessé c'était un
des seuls qui allait flouté je pense de
façon régulière
donc le SMIC était pourri et pour un
slasher c'est plus difficile donc tout
ça fait que il faut se baser sur des
flashs qu'on a vu dans la saison et puis
encore plus je pense sur des moments en
fait où il est où il est arrivé à jouer
parce que il y a quand même des matchs
où il montre des choses qui sont
vraiment très intéressantes au niveau du
du 4ème shoot où on aura sortir des
écrans pour balancer des shoot où il n'a
pas été aidé le pourcentage à la limite
à trois points il est pas trop pourri
quoi
c'est un tout petit c'est un petit
volume 72 72 tiers prix ça fait 1,2 par
Max
mais il y a eu des flashs de shoot en
4ème shoot et en et pas qu'on se potable
qui était intéressant il y avait des
flashs aussi à la création moi je l'ai
trouvé je trouvais qu'il faisait des
bons choix quand ils avaient ballon en
main parce que ça il faut en parler
aussi il y a quand même beaucoup de
créateurs dans l'équipe entre Anthony
blacks comme un dit Manu les
les trois ils ont des pourcentages
pourcentages qui sont très hauts donc il
fallait quand lui avait le ballon moi
j'ai trouvé qu'il faisait des choses pas
mal il faisait des choses pas mal à
certains moments de la saison qui
peuvent donner espoir sur plusieurs
facettes de son jeu et
tu vois il est il a un taux à sister
nover qui est limite mais qui se trouve
qui montre que ça reste aussi
[Musique]
pas du tout il fait des très bons moi je
trouvais que c'est quand tu te mettais à
faire des bases elles étaient elles
étaient précises elles étaient dans le
rythme du jeu et
rien qu'avec sa vivacité il faut le dire
quand même son joueur qui est hyper
rapide qui est très vif quoi très très
vif
dans ce qui fait dans ces prises de
décision
et moi je l'ai trouvé pas mal là-dessus
et précis qu'est-ce qu'il faut débloquer
en fait c'est quoi le la clé pour avoir
un x-mice qui est au niveau du du
ranking pas peut-être pas durant King de
précédent mais du ranking alors toi tu
viens de ce qu'il a le plus bas chez
nous tu as 30e mais
au niveau des entre 10 et 15 quoi ce que
il a attendu là entre 10 et 20 ok
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'il fasse
l'équipe qui leur soit qu'est-ce qu'il
faut développer
moi si c'est mon cas que je le drame je
veux qu'il devienne un peu plus
polyvalent en fait parce que je sais pas
si il aura une vraie carrière s'il fait
que du que du slashing fait petit et que
d'attaquer pour moi il doit apprendre à
faire autre chose notamment vu sa taille
c'est un 64 donc
93 bonjour
je dis quoi 96
avec chaussures aujourd'hui c'est les
tailles d'un meneur quoi absolument donc
c'est faut qu'il arrive à ça en fait
c'est un tout faut qu'il arrive à
devenir un peu plus volant et notamment
du tir parce qu'on a vu que c'est il y a
certains matchs où franchement il a
retirait vraiment pas mal et bon on sent
que c'est son jeu quoi on sent que
c'était naturel que il aimait ça et
ouais c'est vraiment de la polyvalence
moi je trouve qu'il qui doit apprendre à
faire il est un peu porté la balle aussi
donc on a eu comme disait Julien il y a
eu
[Musique]
le meilleur scénario c'est quoi qu'il
soit dans une équipe vraiment tellement
nulle qu'il est plein de minutes
presque après tu vois dans le règne je
15 15 20 là je l'ai sous les yeux
le meilleur du pire parce que c'est le
20e c'est Houston et est-ce que c'est un
bon job pour lui je pense que c'est
mauvais par exemple Houston mais au
dessus tu as du Golden State Miami Los
Angeles
Utah et Atlanta ce qui est pas forcément
nous non plus des bons contextes pour
lui parce que c'est des équipes plus ou
moins Contenders
qui vont vouloir jouer les play-offs ou
le play-in donc c'est peut-être Utah en
fait tu as un truc comme ça et de venir
à terme peut-être une sorte de Jordan
klaxon tu vois ouais ouais je vois bien
un bon scorer qui sort du banc qui se
lâche et c'est vrai que il avait montré
un High School qui avait atout pour
faire ça mais du coup l'année prochaine
toi tu le fais quoi tu tu tu le fais
l'important c'est quoi c'est qu'il est
des minutes ou plutôt qui se renforce
musculairement
moi je pense faut qu'il reprenne
confiance de ce de ce manque de temps de
jeu qui est indépendant de sa volonté
mais voilà qui qui reprennent un peu
confiance en lui et moi je lui donne des
minutes en seconde unique je vous donne
des minutes en sortie de bain voilà
vas-y shoot moi ce que tu sais faire
quoi
ok
Julien est-ce que est-ce qu'on a
[Musique]
lorsque j'ai lu ce que j'ai entendu dans
les dans les interviews c'est que c'est
un gars qui maîtrise la communication il
est exposé depuis très jeune
lorsqu'ils c'est un lycée où il y a
quand même pas mal de monde qui est
passé
donc il est pas comment dire c'est un
endroit où on est quand même bien exposé
des lycées il y a eu une embrouille en
fait son arrivée High School il a il a
failli ne pas jouer en fait son année
seniors il y avait un problème de papier
et apparemment d'après ce que j'ai lu il
a très très bien négocié tout ça la
communication était parfaite donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il est bien entouré le
papa l'air assez présent dans
et la famille en général dans son
parcours et après quand tu écoutes les
interviews il y en a une où il sort d'un
screammage à Washington justement
peut-être que Washington serait une
bonne option pour lui je sais pas
combien ils sont puisque
ils vont être dans un processus de
reconstruction donc dans ce à la fin de
ce stream il fait une interview il y a
10 11 journalistes autour de lui et il
répond comme je sais pas Kobe Bryant tu
vois il tourne la tête n'importe quelle
question il répond alors il maîtrise la
langue de bois de façon magnifique mais
il y a aucune hésitation on a pas
l'impression que c'est un gamin quoi qui
parle vraiment il a l'air assez mature
par rapport à ça après moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un bon équipier
d'après ce que j'ai lu à droite à gauche
parce que c'est ben presque c'est du de
l'enfumage ou pas et puis sur le terrain
il a quand même c'est un gars qui a du
caractère il est revenu comme ady Manu
il revient il y a plusieurs blessures
ils sont tout le temps quoi ils se
cachent pas en défense il donne tout ce
qu'il a avec défauts on attaque il a osé
prendre les shoots même jusqu'au bout
les trois les deux derniers matchs de la
marche Mendes c'est un petit peu la cata
pour lui au niveau du shoot mais il sait
pas qui c'est pas caché je pense que
c'est un gars qui a du tempérament
effectivement voilà avec un petit peu de
muscu pour épaissir le haut du corps
parce qu'au niveau des contacts en
finition au Cercle c'est un petit peu
compliqué
en gros sans son shoot alors moi tu vois
Manu je suis allé je suis très très
mauvais dans les comparaisons et Alex le
sait à chaque fois c'est la cata quand
je sors
il a peur là il a très très peur de
cuisiner moi je pense que comme alors
comme plafond je sais pas comment on dit
tu vois comme scénario meilleur scénario
moi j'enverrai du quintalview squale
alors je sais que tout de suite vous
allez dire mais qu'est-ce qui raconte
défenseur fort d'un coup
dans le style assez polyvalent et moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il allait les
épaules et les
tu vois il a plus de choses dans la tête
que le
non que celui de Manu
ça pourrait être voilà plus il pourrait
être un peu plus cérébral et puis s'il
met tout à l'endroit
il est il est petit mais il a une
envergure assez grande moi je trouve
qu'ils ont plus grand que sa taille
c'est vrai
mais du coup ça veut dire que toi ton
meilleur scénario tu mets de côté
finalement ce capacité de Slash parce
que qui est ici
dans pour dire finisseur ouais ça se
rejoint un peu hein
ce que vous dites mais du coup bon rôle
player quoi mais pas un mec du coup qui
se rase trop un loterie si on si on
on va un peu plus loin si on a si on
comment dire on interprète ce que vous
venez de dire est-ce que votre quel est
votre conviction intime pour finir sur
Nick Smith voilà que est-ce que vous
vous y croyez est-ce que vous vous y
croyez plus que la moyenne est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va être un buste
voilà c'est vraiment ce que vous dit
votre instinct
moi j'ai peur je suis pas
ouais je suis pas je sais pas je sais
pas que je suis pas fan mais je
[Musique]
je sais pas j'ai vraiment beaucoup trop
de questions sur lui notamment le sa
finition en fait je trouve qu'il arrive
pas très très bien à finir aussi que ce
soit au contact et ça ça me fait peur il
est trop dans le flotteur pour moi donc
on a appris qui c'était pas forcément
une bonne chose quand on était trop dans
le flotteur et j'ai regardé un peu de
film que j'ai trouvé sur en High School
il était déjà comme ça il allait aussi
avec beaucoup aussi mais il était très
très flotteur également donc ça coupe
unteur il y a pas une évolution
constante même s'il ajoute 17 marches
donc c'est compliqué mais donc moi sur
rien que sur ces aspect là je j'ai un
peu de doute et le et le 70 15% au
lancer ne me convainc pas trop trop non
plus quoi
[Musique]
puis je me dis que cette année il a
passé à rattraper juste son retard pour
jouer et qu'on l'a pas vu d'évolution
aussi peut-être à cause de ça donc moi
j'ai mis une pièce a dessus quand même
et je me dis qu'il est bien entouré
parce qu'il connaît pas mal de joueurs
NBA je mets une petite pièce quand même
dans les fins de vingtième
t'as les lunettes qu'on te pique 20 21
22 franchement c'est typiquement le pari
à faire quoi comme ils avaient fait sur
kaaris la verte par exemple il y a
quelques années ou un ou les Clippers
qui ont eu des pics aussi comme ça c'est
en fait c'est un pari à pour moi c'est
un pari si tu es les net si tu dis vas-y
fin de c'est s'il tombe jusque là tu dis
vas-y c'est c'est
il peut tomber c'est un risque moyen
mais tu as un gros gros reward aussi
rappelez-vous de Brandon Boston
qui avait glissé très très très loin au
second tour la seconde tour ouais au
second tour et c'était un peu le même
scénario il était vu très haut top 10
avant son année NCA et puis trop fait tu
vois enfin on y repensant c'est un ils
ont un peu les mêmes lacunes une force
tu vois c'était des joueurs comme ça
assez dans le même plus ou moins même
morphotype physique tu as même plus ou
moins même style de jeu même si Boston
était beaucoup plus shooter qu'au
qu'autre chose
ça se
ça match un peu donc pas forcément
rassurant mais un risque à prendre voilà
ce qu'on peut dire de Nicolas
junior ce joueur d'art comme ça qui est
donc le dernier profil sorti que vous
venez d'écouter il y en a plein d'autres
à écouter que ce soit sur Youtube ou
j'ai plateforme d'écoute n'importe quel
on est surtout et c'est aussi à l'écrit
sur envergure.co à bientôt tout le monde